hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within now
this place is absolutely decrepit and
decaying I have a feeling that's Rubik
doing but I'm gonna get to the bottom of
it and I'm gonna see what else he's
waiting for me did I hear the jingle
jangle of a monster over is there
anything here I should know about I
haven't really explored the deep oh okay
there mister wheelchair don't do that to
me I need to find out if there's
anything that I need okay I'm kind of
filling out the map but not enough I
know there's a lot of pieces that I've
missed so I don't think I'm ever gonna
get a full picture and I don't even know
what a full picture would do for me I
don't have any keys left I don't have
any open saves so alright I guess I'm
done nothing else gonna happen right
[Music]
so anyway I already upgraded I did that
and I handled all of that so you guys
didn't have to see my poor
decision-making and now we're about to
make our way to the hospital so that we
can get back to the bottom of what is
really going on here hello whoa hi over
there you're probably not normal humans
so you look like you might be released
down below in some strange fashion to
cause a battle arena of sorts where I
faced off against you look chest high
walls sniper bullets perfect okay
who do I need to shoot what am I looking
at oh okay bye there you go gonna need
to shoot that guy in his head I could
have just made it fine diamon quick I
don't know I could have popped him in
the back of the head because that's
where that guy was vulnerable cuz he had
the iron mask on well that's some
dramatic music but what's the point
Lulu it's pretty hard to sneak in broad
daylight
I'm soon that I'm not gonna get very far
with that hey buddy hey buddy
hey what's dude over there oh yeah
whatever yeah I think I'm just gonna
have to face off with everyone anyway so
and now he's gonna find me who suppose I
could take him out though this would be
a silent kill wouldn't it if I've
managed to hit him from here don't move
yeah I did it silent but deadly I don't
know if that's good was that good
I don't know I did it anyway I kind of
forgot that the crossbow was a silent
kill do I have it I don't think I have
anything left to craft up anymore I mean
that dramatic music still going strong
now I don't have anything I gotta get
more but there haven't been enough traps
anywhere and they're having to spend the
depository of normal harpoons which
there was before like before it was like
everywhere I go I was getting normal
boots what the hell
where'd you come from No
okay so we're back into this game huh
[ __ ]
well I didn't kill him that did like two
points of damage it dick whoa nice
faceplant brah
Oh some epic maneuvering you really got
yourself into the water over there I'm
sure there's monsters so where did that
guy pop up whoa all right then
that guy's got a gun but that guy's got
something get some in his hand oh is
that a shotgun
that's a shotgun ain't it
I got a shotgun with your name on it
yeah yeah yeah go ahead and shoot oh you
shot too bad oh crap I can burn him burn
out baby ha whoosh oh no it's like a
sawed-off shotgun guy animal for me
no I'm drained on ammo oh they're just
coming out one at a time ok you get shot
whoo hey my YouTube whoa he's got a
crossbow
Wow okay that's not fair
you're naked too god you're so gross all
righty then this is not going well
tomato god oh I'm such an idiot I forgot
I had another gun here nope that's out
of ammo too
Wow oh that's right I had a bajillion
sniper bullets that should have been
taking them out from a distance I'm a no
profession well this is extremely
painful
I'm probably gonna die yeah Oh God Oh
God fall off him okay I'm dead yep there
I go to pieces well let's pretend like
that never happened ah did nothing my
hell was right on him damn it damn it
damn dag damn it damn it damn it damn it
dagnabbit Damon okay we're back to where
we failed so let's do this right this
time so now that I know that guys over
there I can't do this
oh hi friend uh you like a bullet to
that foul that one gotcha that one got
some real good I'm good what how are you
alive exploded you literally exploded
not even figuratively explosion that
guy's got a shotgun it's shot a man huh
so how about how about we do a little
boy where you going
what no not okay
okay thank you
can I pick those up why can't I get the
stuff that he's using oh I see what I
gotta do I gotta get past here Oh gonzo
so I can go up here then I can bypass
what they're doing they were probably
gonna come out infinitely if I didn't
see that it what L is this Oh goodbye oh
my god yeah he's serious oh god oh god
oh god no no no no oh god no not again
Oh baby drop down boom baby okay
so what did that guy shoot oh that looks
like a mine or something some sort of
trap can i disarm that should I try why
not
so I got to sapper rifle bullets no
shotgun shells I got some pistol ammo
that I picked up there's only a few guys
left in there should be able to blast
their heads with these things if I'm
accurate enough what no
come on blow up blow up blow up blow up
blow up okay bye
that's not okay did I blast his head
good got him got him from a distance Oh
next sound let's see hell does a delayed
response here argh you got nothing you
got nothing man you got a whole lot of
nothing
oh so sad for you oh you're just here to
give me bullets I see how this works
come on oh it's not what you came for
ah yeah yeah yeah you all suck
what's that oh oh that's right he's okay
hand there we go ml for you huh oh I see
yeah
Booker do it would stop being such a
Sally sue
oh come on why did it not explode it's
pretty there ah
come on this is my coup de Gras oh come
on
well now I'm literally out of bullets
oh really annoying oh come on
laughed I did get him okay I did get him
I did get it but a lot of good that's
gonna mean I don't have anything that
can finish him off he's shot his own guy
oh I have a little cocoon of capers I'm
gonna get shot I forgot I had grown a
days so about these grenades that I've
heard so much about
oh god you suck suck so much you suck on
fire okay Lisa give me pistol ammo back
it seems to be the one gun that they
gave me a lot of ammo of actually
probably just upgraded my pistol just
because I'm always gonna have that look
I don't know yeah I have not gotten
Magnum bullets imagine those are much
bigger than normal bullets what a
didgeridoo SHhhh all of this was just a
bunch of poop oh I got more to go oh
really I'm not done yet
all right then I don't care bring it on
bring it on your goober
wait you got for me I got plenty of
pistol ammo you are mess with now you're
on mess with my black ha all right fine
musky nothing yeah musky it's one sniper
bullet Wow one bullet rule them all I
have a syringe but I need to use them up
sell both yeah that felt good all right
I did not take much damage true that was
mostly just that last guy pepper and me
in the face with bullets
can't complain too much what do we got
here okay haha I know I know I know yeah
there you
and that did Oh friends there's a lot of
gearboxes oh I see
Wow you're gonna make this fun aren't
you you go goes the got in it goes the
brains yeah another guy coming up this
way no thank you yes perfect there we go
burn burn push all right he's gone so I
can all the kapu love that guy wait I
got it over here
Oh Wichitans count on this suck downs I
guess he went limp where's that other
guy guys down always over there alright
then I got another one
Bob all right there
oh that got him okay good so now I can
just heat up the butt
what but oh you went limp again okay so
that was it for me right no I'm so bad
I'm so bad at all my incredible skill
one me through the day
that guy is definitely dead the guy went
limp over here so I'm assuming he's dead
Burnham just in case hey it was it um
and then I go home right
I think I'll believe that other guy had
some like stuff for me as plenty of gear
boxes up top so I'm assuming I'm gonna
be able to craft up some spear shotgun
shells good because it just ran out of
that um if I rotate you yes that is
still loaded up so I'm gonna use that
from now on just because it has it gone
off is better but I has it give me a lot
of stuff is this gonna be one of those
shooting gallery type deals it is oh
it's so shooting gallery I need to use I
need to crafts and stuff let's just go a
standard poon I like got the one okay
great okay it's real quickly
all right then whoa God what the hell
dick fall down okay I wasted bullets
time to get that thing to explode I
gotta be whoa that don't look good fall
over thank you oh thank you fall over
thank you
god this is easy oh thank you what what
the hell is this supposed to be this
easy what am I looking at
what am I supposed to be looking at the
guy who was there but now he's not
follow over thank you
call over oh you didn't fall over fall
over damn you
oh okay yeah yeah burn baby oh that's
not good oh I need uh need me me me me
need need use it while you're crossing
please okay so if I just stay down those
guys aren't gonna be too much of a
bother
okay wait a minute it's not that bad
okay hey I guess I'm all right okay
I'll just be on my way scusi scusi
god I need more supplies that was uh
that was an experience I was reminding
me of that one time a dead space didn't
like it then either I know I'm drawing a
lot of parallels to other horror games
but I've played a lot of horror games
I'm a lot of parallels to draw I can't
hold it against you I still like this
game
oh but Oh blue I'm Booker Sebastian
what do I got going on here rody oh I
had to walk through it yes yeah no it
was a cardboard brain energy huh I'll
take some I could use energy yes please
oh that's fancy give me more give me
more
ah ah you [ __ ]
you piece of [ __ ] why ah I knew if I
press my luck I would do it but god damn
you putting that tiny-ass blah whatever
I tried to pick up the items I didn't
try to get more I wasn't trying to be
greedy
[Music]
okay then I go on man I need to let's
try let's go sir see what we got huh you
want do me huh
Oh stupid to me
good thing I got one of Lee's good
straight bull testosterone right in the
heart great for my health where am I
going okay everything fine fine I
gambled and I lost whatever I was
actually hoping that I would die so I
would have wouldn't have to use that now
but whatever I got him I'll use it okay
this looks like a place where they'd be
some map fragments then on the
whiteboard no nothing really reminds me
has seen from left 4 dead when they're
going through the offices to get drowned
whoa Oh music oh I would have missed
that door good thing that playing it
excuse me BAM no time to open it slowly
Colonel Sebastian Castellanos almost six
months since the accident
Mehra and I drift further apart every
passing week I have to stay strong but
it's easy so easy to drown my thoughts
in whiskey I figure as long as it
doesn't affect my work what I do on my
own time is private
I finally got mirror to open up to me
about the accident now I'm more worried
than ever I don't know what's worse the
fact that Mira is becoming paranoid and
maybe losing her mind but the fact that
she was proposing that the fire wasn't
an accident could be real I owe it to
her to trust her instincts but if
they're correct god help whoever did
this such a sad story the same room
it stills decrepit as ever back here I
can yeah you should expect this by now
no you've done this many times now you
know that you come back here to save so
are you in here no no Mara could you
clean up a little like what 20 minutes
are you going lady there you going stood
up okay to watch me alright fine by me
okay got one more key so hopefully it's
gonna give me some good come on let's
feel lucky tonight I mean it's always
something good so I guess I can't
complain
that's so rundown is this what it means
what I'm losing my mind
Rubik playing with me okay ah you look
pretty good yeah Oh only six alright
thought that was gonna be more I need so
much more than that
how much people have not enough let's go
back out there just popped in to save
and ground a sniper bullets I love the
sniper rifle why can't they give me more
bullets
I just need to find more keys that's
what I need have them enables them not
enough never enough it's probably a key
like hidden in every single level I go
to who knows okay Brandon okay
okay and bomb no okay that's about the
only got a little bit
you only winged me with your giant
explosion there whatever gotcha gotcha
reloading actually got some shotgun
shells so I'll stick with that for now
sniper rifle one yes one bullet I love
it Kidman Kidman
how did Kidman get all the way out here
was she being bounced around all over
the place like me she's not going
nowhere I'll just gather up all the
supplies I need hey suspicious-looking
thermos a weird shadow what is that
anyway why is that protecting that
shadow like that that's intentional
isn't it that's intentional
that's so intentional it's a million
types of intentional looks like spikes
alrighty then is that all you had I'll
be on my way
okay bye
all righty then come on Kidman's in
trouble gotta go find her
oh I don't know I didn't turn my light
on I'm a ding ding what do we got
I can't move okay
can't man upgrade your gun with brain
juice they'll never know where you are
okay
that's a lot of em okay never mind
that's a lot tonight over there oh I
always my bullets then I guess
J
well that's convenient
okay so I need to jump from bills to biz
is that what I'm doing
I hope here I go oh well that's slow do
I need to can I
oh it did I can help Brown sorry I got
some brain on you
oh ho one down all right so that's the
dope rough I guess so
oh god here we go oh
Oh No why did it do that to me
oh I thought it like me okay
oh if I old mounts to all-male a
attacking with F well alright never
known it okay so I got a helper let me
see if I can do this with my pistol so
he knew with my pistol save myself the
extremely valuable oh come on
dammit well not saving me anything
yeah get behind him get behind him
little more more back in his double kill
damn it I jumped again D it anymore
uh-oh y'all shy now okay no chance no oh
god why oh I'm okay
oh the jump mechanics I don't have a
jump button I don't know when I jump all
this plus to go there
god it's such a douche all right
whatever
let's try this again it's not my fault
it's not my fault
please don't be mad at me please all
right
you're if I can get it if I can get on
that normally oh really
that would toss me in the drink again I
would have it very upset yep perfect
one more shooting gallery
okay here we go oh come on why why why
would you do that to me oh god is such
an [ __ ] I'm not doing it it's not my
fault all right all right all right all
right all right all right
don't be a douche today Oh screw you
screw you okay got it
I'll wait for the next one
all right as I look away huh it's nap
time it that guys close
who cares Yoho jump right for him please
tell me that blocked him out
it didn't block him out did it get up
get up on that thing jump on the thing
shut up ass down okay okay good good
thing I did that yeah I should have gone
for the stairs but I didn't see them
first saw the car first then I committed
okay okay I'm gonna save that body
because I think that I can make it over
to the under way what are they Oh
bottles perfect so in one body I think I
hit it from here I can swim
you little quicker quicker thank you
thank you I lost my bottle but that's
all right
bullets Thank You min you're okay you
got it
Bob what are you out of bullets I never
happened to me I'm a master of
conservation so I gotta get it can't
jump over that Oh where that gotta come
from Oh No okay so that's that wait I
can't jump over this really really cool
again with the poopy decisions you're
making me make this is why I wanted that
bottle here we go go go go go go go go
go
tosser oh my god faster this sauce lag
okay get up get up get up get up get up
get up get up get up get a good hey
you're a detective private dick hit that
[Music]
okay all right no need to panic panic is
the enemy panic so it's not gonna make
it no matter what is it go over there
that man oh god oh god why why why why
why why why what are you doing
dump dump dump dump dump such an [ __ ]
oh really there's two of them I should
have saved that body such douchery
don't worry Kidman I got this
finally got the timing down I don't have
to do it again oh man that's a bit too
stressful for my tastes I would rather
have something toned down a little bit
the fact how perhaps if I have to dyed
by facial expressions things will go
better for me so since I helped her out
by wasting my own boats I'm gonna see
yeah it's gonna make your chances of
survival a little bit better
Hey
oh come on come on you son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
oh really both bullets that's what I
wanted yeah [ __ ] you
girl happy happy other sales how can you
even see me buddy
okay all right we're good right good
that was not necessary God why did he
look towards me
they threw a bottle whatever whatever
all right Kidman
good job surviving getting yourself back
to new a corner I know God this game
just wants to mess with me oh look it's
more of them can you shoot for me please
tell me you're better than Jojo
there you go see you had bullets okay
you son of a [ __ ] he's gotta suck so
bad so bad shooter shoot him shoot him
shoot him shoot him what's out here they
go to your place
shoot him shoot him shoot him shoot him
oh god oh why did I God [ __ ] a grey
go have any grenades left yes one please
die horribly okay now's a lot of body
parts going everywhere
alright let's take a breather here let's
calm down let's review no anomalies
mistakes or my fault I'm actually losing
my voice because I've been screaming in
aggravation there's something in my eye
I'm losing my upper range and if that
wasn't my fault none of that was my
fault I know what I'm doing
that was just a game being bull okay so
now that I got that out of my system I
can calm down and I can save my voice
cuz I got more to record after this oh
okay
so let's relax hope you guys are
enjoying the ride of marker blood God
get out of my eye everything once you
graduate me everything once so run me
through the wringer okay
this better be where the secret is
because I think the elevator is where
it's supposed to go
this better have some goodies for me to
enjoy said I don't have to kill anyone
this sounds it looks like that's that
okay get out of my way get out of my way
get out of my way get out of my way get
out of my way outta my way
alright okay
everyone be happy be happy
yay it feels good to win it feels good
there's just an eyelash in my eye right
now there's an eyelash stuck in my eye
all right
ever since the church ever since the
church
yeah Joseph and I he's in bad shape
or at least he was when I left song what
about the boy from the hospital Leslie I
found him in a cage he freaked and ran
though yeah okay so basically everything
is awful um
this reminds me of a level from was it
painkiller
you remember painkillers anybody played
that it was an awesome game and some of
the coolest varied environments at least
the first game was the rest of the games
weren't that great but that's okay the
old-school run-and-gun shooter
I miss those my voice is seriously a
little bit thrashed
I keep getting aggravated and I went a
little out of control and I'm letting my
voice get problems but I'm okay there's
still something in my eye
but I'm calming down I'm nice and calm
I am collected and calm yeah I have no
worries and I am calm I got no strings
to hold me down everybody take a
breather in through the nose out through
the mouth
in through the nose out through the
mouth good excellent my voice is gonna
suffer
I think we've all been seeing strange
things have you been having any
nosebleeds headaches no why
Joseph Juana it's like he was turning
into one of those things maybe it
doesn't affect everybody no I'm pretty
sure it affects everybody you may just
be the most sane out of all of us please
tell me you see these mannequins in
front of me Bob
okay I really am losing a lot of my
upper range right now which is not too
terribly good so I'm gonna take the rest
of this episode in a calm lyrical
fashion I promise not to scream because
I'm turning up the volume of my
recording which means if I go loud it
will over blow the mic you know you
won't be able to hear anything oh is
this the mannequin part I bet it is good
still an eyelash stuck in my eye
that's not good
bleeding from the mouth oh no I refuse
okay back into normal mode oh look out
Kidman
Hey
what what happened what happened no you
can't do that
No oh hi oh you started turning into a
monster you attacked me I'm sorry but
you're tainted now you might try to stop
me through you wait what are you talking
about oh oh so she's the one who's
unaffected by all of this
Oh Rubik in my mind okay
Rubik in my Rubik in my mind so now
lesley is that you Leslie is that you I
knew it I was gonna say Leslie don't
worry I'm here to help
Leslie that's good just a little more
Leslie let me in I'm a friend I'm not
like the doctor
I won't affect you I won't try to hurt
you I'm trying to help trying to help
oh why did Leslie barricade it or maybe
Leslie didn't barricade it okay
so now I need to use my lower register
and speak in a softer voice but
hopefully this isn't a problem so now
that I'm using tile oh oh good yeah
oh very good oh great this is of course
the perfect time for me to not have my
voice okay yes I get it I need to get
rid of the dangerous gasps danger
flammable
okay so I'll put out my light and I
won't fire a thing okay hang on wait one
moment I have something for you some
bolts I've had best not use the
explosive version that would be bad is
this someone in here that needs to be
hunted that sounds fairly precarious is
someone over there
that's not good what do we got what do
we got what do we got oh oh it's one of
them none okay so I need to not
antagonizing what am i picking up I
don't know what I just picked up in
there oh that's good
way over there yeah there was a weird
noise that you definitely heard and was
true okay we're fine we're fine
we'll need to pick up another one we're
totally fine everything is as it should
be
why are there so many damn mannequins
everywhere and why is this gas flammable
who's strange memory is all of this and
you think that guy dragging his big
metal club would cause some sparks
somewhere but then again maybe not still
very calm still very quiet matches would
not be a good idea he's somewhere there
would be a logical solution crap way
over there
yeah go look at that I actually have to
be selphie this time that wasn't working
out too well for me before but hopefully
we'll be okay I can't see anything
zero monster over there what are you
doing by yourself lady okay
I see well too bad for you I'm gonna
stab you in the face me ways that Rubick
oh no it's not of course not okay he's
gonna come this way yeah yeah that's
right
I won't always turn it around what is he
turning now he is turning around
okay let's guys done
okay perfect
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa not cool bruh
yeah yeah yeah Oh what are you doing
pick a direction oh come on really
gaah screw you you lost me in the
darkness you have no idea where I am
a shadow in the night I'm a shadow in
the night my god did he really lose me
did he but we did we did it's too foggy
do dark okay what the hell these guys
are so sporadic and twitchy it's not
cool
are you I'm your friend
come here friend okay good good good
good good and they gave me an axe
perfect I need to heal myself very badly
right there where's the other one I hear
another one I'm not gonna burn him
that's for damn sure
whoa whoa what is that
what is that
oh I got you okay so if I can stab kill
one i can still axe the other wait i can
pick that up
Oh picked it right from under your nose
I don't need you anymore I can turn off
the gas which would be very nice okay
there's one more over there
leaves behind a fence so I'm okay okay
everything's hunky-dory
come on yeah this definitely wouldn't
make all the gas dissipate immediately
but hopefully it would do some good and
it immediately dissipated good no all
right I just make my way back use the
key card Bob's your uncle and I'm out of
here
God these freaky ass bins of mannequins
I would ask why but I don't even want to
know the answer okay and we're through
are we out of here
oh yeah out of here good okay okay I
think I gave my voice enough of a break
oops yeah too low I think I gave my
voice enough of a break so hopefully
this will be a little bit better for you
guys and a little bit better for me ha I
know some people like my lyrical
softness Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe
I don't know if I'm happy or very upset
because I've had my frustration for my
time I don't need more
oh they got to give me so much more ammo
I am way low on everything right now
hey what are we
[Music]
journals Sebastian Castellanos as if I
don't have enough to deal with
personally and professionally Joseph and
I have been assigned a rookie to train
great babysitting duty Kidman is young
and green but as that sense of
entitlement that all the rookies have
these days I always catch you're giving
me sideways glances whenever I have to
bend the rule book a lit a bit she
doesn't understand that sometimes it's
part of the job if you want to break a
case personality-wise she's a cold fish
distance it's their job to observe and
assist but sometimes it feels like she's
a scientist looking at samples in a
petri dish more like she's merely
watching us instead of trying to learn
from us there's something about her that
gets under my skin but I can't quite put
my finger on it Joseph as usual tells me
that I'm being oversensitive I think
he's got a crush on her maybe all I know
is that I've got
keep things close to the vest when she's
around yeah wouldn't want someone to
stop me from drinking and screaming
about bad things
[Music]
what okay there you do you've smashed
you now don't even know anymore a serial
killer investigator missing aha identity
and fate of investigator unknown case
goes cold in countryside serial killer
investigation police and I lead
investigator missing well there's a bit
of conflicting information here someone
would know if she was missing whoa maybe
maybe maybe not I got another key that
might help me get out of my way lady
all right then miss lady I swear she's
getting on my nerves
everything in this game is trying to get
on my nerves I was just saying how much
I was having fun all right let's try
this said having on this side a while
heal it good what do you got for me baby
green goop I'll take it
need the upgrade I guess 7,000 not bad
don't take I just open the store why
does it take me so long okay
I'll save goody goody gumdrops gonna be
the gumdrops gonna get a gumdrops no yes
please go accept thank you all right so
now I'll upgrade and we'll move on I
really wish I really wish now that I
didn't get out get a gravida because I
have so many things that I need recorded
but
I'll persevere I will live on it always
happens that's what happened in Octodad
and I did play the octave at shorts I
don't know if those are out yet but
they're gonna be anyway what I'm gonna
do I am going to save up money and I'm
going to finish upgrading my pistol
because I want my pistol B to be the
number one numero Nuno I can't talk
never bind me how long my pistol to be
the best is basically what I'm trying to
say it's gonna make you all like heck
you might be a good idea fighter not
spread all my upgrades around I'd have a
really good pistol right now okay any
other goodies I should know about any
other secrets probably jumping down
there would be a bad idea
Kidman thinks I'm an [ __ ] she was
just waiting to shoot me in the face
what's all admit she knew she was just
waiting for the opportunity and besides
I saved her life
well was that a magnum bullet I think it
might have been was a big whatever it
was yes one of everything great exactly
what I needed
okay so there's a way to go through
there but what about up there
which way is the puzzle way oh this is
circles back never mind
I thought it was something else okay oh
[Music]
ah more mannequins really wondering what
the whole deal is with these things are
nothing over here okay I hear something
laughing do I hear laughing okay
is then just wind rustling through
because I swear it sounds like laughing
oh okay okay okay all right okay thank
you
all right probably sitting a waste with
my shotgun but not like I had much of
anything else
hey all right so can I open any of these
no point hiding it's nothing
come on there's got to be something all
right whatever
okay moving on moving on everything is
fine go over here here precariousness
I'll just take a breather on the
precarious bridge perfect and done okay
that's normal
totally lucky that that went that way
that that was what's up next it's gonna
happen next
please tell me that it all got it's Jojo
oh all right fine
well that's the end of the chapter
really you can end it there I just saved
this is the weirdest chapter finishes
I've ever seen like it makes no sense it
did before now I have no idea what it's
trying to do hello moon on thank god
you're all right
how did you get here
uh wasn't easy at least I haven't had
any more
episodes good to see you too I wish I
could say the same
hey I think I might have found us some
transportation yay what is that a
military school bus that thing's huge
it's very armored only one way to find
out hi Kidman how you doin
what are you doing
yay
thanks to get beer
oh wait any good
yeah oh no indeed do I get to kill that
thing yeah damned something so did I
just shoot it
okay so I just shoot it right
oh I did get it tight I think anyway
whoa what you don't like that
hey good for you
whoa what is that Chris Chris Chris
Brody Brody Brody Brody okay rocket
rookie let me just grab all the rest of
the Sam oh I'm in no hurry don't worry
about me come on
Kumasi me begun
and I will just do anything from a
distance it's probably very scripted
what I can't go over here
okay
but I color quick okay bye and it's dead
right
alright then probably not very long I
guess I know why they ended the chapter
there because this is all going on whoa
what oh hi
how about you go to down thank you very
much they say give us a box of bullets I
was awfully nice of them okay thank you
Sebastian you are a great help
good job where are they
god this is an interesting dynamic has
just changed shoot him in the head
god damn it Joe Joe is so unhelpful
hey I shot it out of his hand all right
another guy with a mask not an
invincible mask oh here we go
Thank You Kidman you're such a great
help you're not even shooting where why
damn it I thought they might have been
giving me stuff where are they
come on
more of them on the move dan there we go
Kaito Kaito
burn baby burn
oh whoa hey where'd you come no oh god
that's bad Jojo take the blast thank you
I didn't want to do that would you stop
it
I was trying got him right in the face
okay
whoa okay he's gonna fall over then I'm
out of bullets
okay good thing they're some convenient
in here right this is like the least
intense moment in the game because I'm
just I'm in the shooting gallery
shooting calories aren't all that fun
these guys heads aren't exploding okay
yeah I'm enjoying myself where do you do
hang like he's falling to the ground
randomly okay yeah
God who leave what ones to do that one
this one that refused to die what about
over there oh good thanks Jojo you did a
great job man that really wasn't all
that successful like there's other
points in this with like the water
monster that was really stressful that
was like I was like just kick back and
relax time okay where are we going is
the big guy gonna be back yet more
bullets for me
any minute now any minute now keep us
left
okay
well friendlies back I didn't reload my
gun
okay it's not moving
whoa Sam open some of it
in the face
just go
- God Kim in my big autonomous
I mean this give me I need to speed this
[Music]
come on
I'll say if this thing moving yes
so sickness isn't it it just oozes in
Manasquan it's bad
no shotgun pressing arrows gonna pieces
ah here we go
how are you even driving on this
Hey
I think this stop physics works whoa
nice nice nice okay there Joseph I've
got a theory we seem to be moved around
an awful lot almost as if by someone's
will so it's nearly impossible to get
any sense of the geography around here
but the light beacon mental hospital
it's always in the distance uh-huh this
thing you found me hooked up to I've
seen it in more than one place yeah so
if I it seems like it's the same exact
one but it's hard to be sure the thing
that I've noticed is that each time I
run across one I seen any closer to the
lighthouse it could be a coincidence but
like I said it seems as if there is some
intelligence behind yeah we ought to cut
to the chase and just head straight for
the hospital
exactly nice work detective yeah nice
work Jojo still hate your [ __ ] let more
directly toward the hospital
Oh No
oh god damn No just get us out of here
who shot him there's an ambulance there
there might be some kind of first aid
any of them on board
how does some random bullet come out of
nowhere to shoot him because he was too
smart is that what it was
Oh didn't realize that it gnaws here
okay I'm in no hurry right I don't need
to rush this do it go over there yeah
weird I know
what is that lady in the back dune for a
move you guys are gonna be all kinds of
fun aren't you you guys are gonna really
do it anyway I'm actually all that time
so I gotta end this episode here so
thank you all so much for watching this
has been one heck of a ride oh man
aggravation aggravation aggravation I'm
gonna get my voice a little bit of a
breather before I continue on but thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for videos that I've done and
as always I will see
[Music]